last night GLAAD gathered some of the
biggest LGBTQ stars and allies for
together in Pride you are not alone the
livestream was to benefit LGBTQ centers
that are dealing with the COBIT 19
pandemic one of the hosts Canadian Lilly
Singh caught up with queer I star
Jonathan van Ness talked about the
importance of mental health during this
strange time I think it's okay to kind
of take a little off the fast phone it's
okay if you're feeling like you don't
want to change your clothes all the time
you know I think it is about how we are
feeling whatever makes you feel calm
during this time anyway you should do
and if that means sweatpants with a
blazer something else and absolutely
correct I love that Jonathan who shared
that he is HIV positive
last year spoke about the importance of
ending the stigma attached to HIV the
more that we can talk about it and the
more that we can be visible I think that
really helps undetectable equals
untranslatable so when you you know are
HIV positive but you're undetectable you
are not at risk of transmitting the
virus the events other host Billy
Eichner spoke with Dan levy about his
own journey within the queer community
and just how far we have gone looking
back on my own experience I think I had
a lot of loneliness I felt like I was
alone through a lot of my teens and you
know early 20s even back then even in
the early 2000s we didn't have the same
kind of resources that we have now I
mean I think for me support is the
biggest most crucial part of staying
kind of afloat through the journey of
navigating your sexuality and what it
means to you and how it defines you and
what it does in terms of inspiring the
work that you do
finding friends family if your family is
not supportive hopefully they can learn
and change but you do have other
resources Billy also spoke with star
Adam Lambert about his own personal
journey being queer within the
entertainment industry now the work
we're coming out and it is getting
easier to be a queer openly as you
GQ or non-binary pop artist but you had
to deal with not everyone had to deal
with so how do you make peace with that
one of your thoughts on that it led to
certain things in my career that were
great it definitely taught me a lot very
quickly it taught me what my boundaries
were publicly the cast of Broadway's
latest hit Jagged Little Pill gave a
stellar performance of Alanis a song you
learn from their own homes
[Applause]
you
other celebrities who took part in the
event include Barbra Streisand Melissa
Ethridge Billy Porter Rosie O'Donnell
Michelle visage Ross Matthews bebe Rexha
and so many more Kesha closed the event
with a beautiful performance of rainbow
the event raised over two hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars incredible
so did you watch together in Pride last
night what were some of your favorite
moments how are you dealing with
self-isolation remember you're not alone
let me know in the comments below oh hey
there if you want more LGBTQ news and
exclusive interviews click subscribe or
watch these videos